hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video was sponsored by
squarespace and i will be reviewing
another harper's bazaar
what i in a day by lucy hale but before
we get into it
let me tell you a little bit about my
sponsor squarespace so if you're doing
any kind of business or passion hobby
project these days
you pretty much need a website to
succeed
i am admittedly pretty old school and
even i believe that
now in addition to everything that i do
here on youtube i also coach a lot of
dietitians who want to learn how to blog
and make videos and social media posts
and so
a lot of them struggle with this whole
website thing
i also struggle because i kind of hate
technology but i know that it's
a necessary part of the business so
squarespace is a super intuitive
all-in-one platform that makes it so
easy for
anyone to set up a website blog or
online store
regardless of your niche they have
amazing
blogger features and social media
integration programs
plus extensions for e-commerce if you
sell products
or services online honestly it is so
nice when all the technology just kind
of works together
nicely because i know a lot of us
otherwise struggle with this
way too much so if you're interested in
getting started
you can check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase
of a website or domain also you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
as i will be talking numbers and
portions
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you never miss out on a
video
alright folks let's dive in i
am a breakfast person i think about
breakfast
all the time i like all the meals but i
think breakfast is definitely my
favorite
i like this woman already i too enjoy
a good breakfast all day air day so
yeah girl don't let me down my breakfast
can vary from like
a peanut butter perfect food bar to like
chocolate chip pancakes
with bacon and eggs just kind of depends
on the day i mean
this is why intuitive eating is such an
awesome thing
you know if you're listening to your
body's cues some days it may just want
like a little snacky snack
and sometimes because maybe you exercise
your it small like dinner the night
before
or your hormones are shifting you might
want to
eat like a queen both are legitimate
choices
when you are leaning into those cues as
for those options
in the grand scheme of bars this one
does have over 300 calories so
it would at least give you a little bit
more energy if you were having it as a
standalone meal
but it's still of course a small
standalone meal but we do have a nice
balance of protein from the rice protein
and egg powder fat from the peanut
butter and
carbs from the honey i would probably
still want to see it paired with maybe
like a source of whole fruit
supply a little bit more fiber and
calories but
all in all it sounds like a pretty good
option for a really really light
breakfast now obviously like i said it's
a very light option when compared to the
other end of the spectrum of lucy's
breakfast
aka chocolate chip pancakes with bacon
and eggs
so this would be a heartier option for
hungrier days but it would also be
higher in sodium and saturated fat so we
could kind of meet
halfway and do like an egg and a slice
of bacon
and the bar or pancakes topped with some
of the peanut butter bar diced up
and maybe a little bit of fresh fruit on
top having said that i get that
sometimes you just want to have
bacon eggs and chocolate chip pancakes
and that
is a okay i actually go to sleep
excited about my cup of coffee in the
morning and obviously right now all the
coffee shops are closed so i've been
really becoming buddies with my keurig
and i like a lot of creamer with my
coffee
now you guys know i don't usually
critique
coffee so even if her coffee was like 50
flavored creamer i wouldn't bat an eye
but i will say that if you're trying to
make a diet change i do like lucy's
approach especially with something as
habitual
as your morning coffee so very gradually
making changes to how much sugar you use
in your coffee
can start to actually slowly change your
preferences
without triggering that knee-jerk
deprivation reaction
that you might get if you were to kind
of like quit sugar cold turkey
and we know that feeling deprived
usually results in
giving up on the health-promoting
behavior and even
sometimes swinging to the other extreme
and overeating
this same approach can be applied really
to any meal or
healthy eating habits so for example
let's say habitually you always have a
bowl of ice cream before bed at night
okay so if i'm being honest this example
is me well let's see if i want to change
that and i don't
i might start throwing some berries on
top of the ice cream
then slowly over days or weeks i could
tweak
the ratio of berries to ice cream until
i've added like a serving or two of
fresh fruit
and reduced my added sugar intake for
the day and
just like that i've made a new habit
that's
rooted in enjoyment and not severe
restriction
one slice of wheat toast in the toaster
twice
and almond butter get a good banana and
you chop it up
and then you get some local honey and
you just drizzle that on get your cup of
coffee
seize the day okay so this sounds like
an
awesome breakfast to me uh this rx
almond butter
is made with egg whites almonds and
dates
so you're getting a lot of healthy
monounsaturated fats
two grams of fiber and nine grams of
protein
per two tablespoons serving that's
almost twice the protein
found in traditional almond butter so if
protein
is a priority for you it could be a
really good option but i like that this
breakfast has
carbs from the bread banana and honey
and healthy fats and protein in
the nut butter and even though lucy says
that she probably has
too much almond butter because her
serving is two or three times the one
suggested on the package
i appreciate that she goes with the
amount that works for her
this is a really good reminder that
servings on packages are
not personalized to you or your needs so
if your body guides you to eat
a quarter half double or
four times the recommended serving then
that's probably
the right serving for you my dog elvis
we go for our first walk of the day
around the neighborhood
which varies from like 30 to 45 minutes
we wave at our neighbors we say hello
uh we listen to music we listen to true
crime podcasts
lucy i like you you like breakfast
i like breakfast you like a generous nut
butter to toast ratio
i like a generous nut butter ratio you
like true crime
i love true crime we can be friends
i just got a peloton treadmill and then
i'll do like a live stream yoga
or i'll do a live stream training mate
which is my favorite workout class in la
soul cycle a missile cycle so bad
i just think exercise is the best
medicine research
does suggest that physical activity can
boost self-esteem energy mood
and sleep quality and can reduce your
risk of anxiety
depression dementia heart disease and
cancer
just to name a few of its amazing
benefits
so yeah especially in these challenging
cova times when
a lot of our other coping strategies are
strained
it's really therapeutic to find a way to
move your body that you actually enjoy
i've taught myself to cross stitch right
now i'm cross stitching a little pig
i'm reading and reading a really great
book called where the crawdads sing
which is just like then we go on walk
number two with
beldi a lot of face time with family and
friends because i've been doing this
quarantine alone
so these sound like amazing self-care
strategies in kovid
and i love that she's finding ways to
keep her body and mind
healthy and happy also i'm totally
adding cross stitch a pig
to my kovid stay at home to do list
thanks lucy
the typical lunch for me would be
sushi but like sashimi so just the fish
on top of rice
there's a place near me that does yellow
tail and jalapeno with
yuzu sauce i even like uni which is sea
urchin
i love it all i'm a very adventurous
eater i love a girl who loves food
and uni for example is definitely a food
i was not prepared to hear
get air time on a youtube what i eat in
a day
but i am here for it i also love sashimi
when the fish is super fresh
but if we want to build this into a more
substantial balanced meal that is also a
little bit more
cost conscious i would say we could pair
it with some rice
either as nigiri or on the side
and have a salad or some stir fried
teriyaki vegetables
snacks 24 7. we love
we made pita bread and hummus
any kind of hummus red pepper original
pine nut garlic
celery hearts which is the center of the
celery it's the best part but i also
love this candy called sweet treats and
it's like the healthier candy
i also love a good ice cream bar or
greek yogurt bar i have these chocolate
chip cookie dough ones in my fridge
right now
all great snacks and i like that we're
seeing both sweet and savory options
so pita veggies and hummus is a classic
in my books because
it's the perfect hunger crushing combo
snack with fat
fiber and protein all in a simple
package
these greek yogurt bars that she
mentioned are also looking really great
they've got
five grams of protein and just nine
grams of added sugar so
definitely a good option if you're just
looking for a little something cold
and sweet at the end of the day now as
for smart sweets
one bag of candy like she said has
around 100 calories
it's got no fat just a few grams of
sugar
and as much as 21 grams of
fiber so how do those numbers add up
well depending on if you're shopping in
canada or the us
the company uses a variety of fiber
sources like corn fiber
isomalto oligosaccharides chicory root
and allulose each of which have variable
absorption levels in the gut so this is
what keeps the calories and the neck
carbs
so low now one of smartsuite's big
selling features
is that unlike a lot of low sugar
candies they don't use
sugar alcohols like maltitol to sweeten
their candy
since maltitol can cause a lot of gas
and digestive distress when consumed in
excess
i mean if you want something giggles pun
intended just read the amazon reviews
for the now
discontinued haribo sugar-free gummy
bears there's a reason
why consumers are looking for multitol
free
candy coming out of me but anyways back
to fiber
i am a huge supporter of fiber and
finding little ways to sneak more into
your diet
especially because the vast majority of
people
do not get anywhere near enough so i see
why so many people
love this product but if you naturally
have a really
low fiber diet or if you have ibs
and are sensitive to sugar alcohols you
might also have some digestive
discomfort
from consuming so much fiber in one go
a lot of these fibers are considered
high fodmaps so
if you're not sure i suggest easing into
it with a small
portion to allow your body to adjust at
the end of the day i think there's a
place for
higher fiber candies like these and also
for regular higher sugar candies
depending on your preferences and goals
one is not good
and the other bad lunch sushi
or like a good salad but i love a good
kale salad with
like a blackened salmon i
i like a lot of dressing so it's like
sometimes i even do ranch
i know it's bad it's great ranch is
great ranch is the best thing ever
love that save lucy yes you are my girl
so you can see that she quickly caught
herself from calling
ranch dressing bad and then pivoted to
it being
great this is total evidence to me that
even with
diet culture being overwhelmingly
pervasive
we can slowly start to change the way we
talk
and eventually think about different
foods
but anyways this does sound like a
really great lunch we've got lots of
healthy fats in the salmon
and fiber with the kale i mean we could
definitely
add a little carb in there maybe some
bread on the side or some couscous or
quinoa
in there but judging by lucy's next
lunch pick
it doesn't sound like she's anti-carb a
club sandwich
i made one the other day you butter two
sides
of wheat toast and you brown them and
then in another pan you fry an egg
and on the fried egg you put vegan
cheddar cheese i
grilled up some turkey bacon a
nitrate-free turkey breast
smack that uh yes
this is ticking all the right boxes here
so
we've got protein in the turkey and egg
healthy fats in the avocado
carbs in the bread and lots of veggies
going on
but let's talk for a second about
nitrate free
so nitrates have become a bit of a bad
word in health circles
since we do have research to suggest
that heating up nitrates in foods like
meat
create carcinogenous compounds called
nitrosamines
but are deli meats that are labeled
nitrate-free
actually nitrate-free well in short
not exactly food manufacturers still
cure their nitrate-free bacon or turkey
breast for example
but they rely on natural curing agents
like celery powder
in lieu of synthetic sodium nitrate and
while we don't have any quality research
to suggest that
natural nitrates are healthier than
synthetic ones
most experts think that the effect is
likely the same
and actually there is some concern that
you might actually be getting
more nitrates in nitrate-free foods
since synthetic nitrate amounts are
regulated and capped whereas the amount
of celery powder a food can contain
is not having said that i don't think
that we need to sensationalize or
demonize anything here there are
nitrates in all sorts of the foods that
we consume most notably actually
vegetables and if you're consuming
processed foods in moderation it
shouldn't be a huge concern
so i say that there's totally room for
moderate amounts of processed foods if
you enjoy
them when the bulk of your diet is
coming from whole
unprocessed foods overall diet quality
is
much more important to me than a singled
out ingredient
when it comes to achieving long-term
good health
favorite food city ooh i recently went
to barcelona
this was the weirdest thing i ate in
barcelona peeled
white asparagus mixed with sea urchin
uni
but it was interesting you know i think
that's the coolest thing about travel is
tasting other cultures foods
i 100 agree on both friends
barcelona is a beautiful food city
though i think if we're talking spain
i'm partial to san sebastian but let me
know
below your all-time favorite food city
so usually what i do at work i'll
postmate something
i'm a big soup eater i solely survived
on wonton soup chicken wonton soup
and faux vegetarian faux i think soup
is the ultimate example of why comfort
food
doesn't always need to mean junk food
i mean soup to me is inherently
comforting
especially for us canadians in the dead
of winter
yet it's also a natural base for
building a
super balanced bowl it is also insanely
delicious so that gets huge thumbs up
from me
[Applause]
weekend cheat meal lunch well i usually
if i'm going to cheat
i go cheat meal dinner and
my favorite shoestring french fries
with a buttermilk ranch dressing and
like a
really good burger
oh lucy you failed my cheat meal test
but at least i am with you on loving a
good burger and fries
i am also kind of surprised that she's a
diet coke girl especially
with her cheat meal i always call this
out as like the diet
coke effect you know when people feel
good that they're choosing the
calorie-free diet soda so that
they give themselves permission to go
ham on the burger and fries
now i'm not actually suggesting that
that's what lucy's doing because she
actually seems to have
a pretty solid relationship with food
and maybe she just likes diet coke
i know for me even giving myself full
permission to drink
regular soda i have zero interest in it
because
i don't like the way that the sugar kind
of coats my mouth but i'm just kind of
calling this out as like a fun fact
since i know
so many people fall into that trap so
let me know below if you have fallen
into the whole
diet coke effect mentality at some point
in your life okay so recently i have
fought i've a newfound love of thai
curry
i don't know why it took me 30 years to
discover that i love curry
so i'm on a thai curry phase that's
probably my favorite
meal as of now but also bolognese
i love bolognese i love pasta so it's
interesting that at the start of the
interview
lucy said that you know her breakfast is
always so different
but now she's saying that she eats like
the same
thing day after day until she gets sick
of it and then
moves on now i think a lot of people do
this and it's
possibly a time saving tactic but also a
personality thing
but if you were to ask me what's optimal
nutritionally
i would say that variety is the spice of
life
when we eat the same dish over and over
again
we miss out on the opportunity to get a
wide range of nutrients
in our day and into our week so if lucy
was on the curry train and just was not
ready to get
off she could achieve some variety in
her diet
by switching up the veggies and the
protein and the starches in her curry
so rice chicken and broccoli one day
noodles tofu and carrots another
this way we still get variety while
still delivering the consistency
that we might crave i'm so guilty of
in bed and being like i want a snack i'm
bored i bored eat too
girl no need to be guilty about wanting
a good snack
oh my goodness frozen grapes
it's like eating little popsicles it's
so good when i have a sweet tooth
because i have such a major major sweet
tooth i
always want dessert i always want
something sweet after a meal so if you
learn one thing from this video
freeze your grapes so
true if you haven't frozen grapes you
are missing out and if you want to
really take it to the next level i've
got a recipe in the mindful glow
cookbook where i
soak my grapes in riesling wine
and then i freeze them so lucy my girl
give that a little try when you're
feeling like you need a little
pick-me-up
during the week it will not disappoint
what can we say
about lucy's diet honestly this is
probably one of my favorite harper's
bizarre diet recalls
yet i think we saw a really nice range
of meals and snacks that felt
interesting balanced and non-restrictive
there were some stereotypical
wellness-like foods like greek yogurt
bars
kale salads and hummus we had some fun
foods like chocolate chip pancakes and
bold nazi sauce
and also some inherently balanced yet
not diety dishes
like pho and turkey sandwiches i get the
sense that
lucy isn't afraid of food as i i didn't
hear a lot of diet culture rhetoric
and she describes food with a sense of
gusto
and pleasure she also describes a number
of really healthy self-care activities
that
don't feel restrictive or punishing at
all and she likes true crime so
i can forgive her for the whole cheat
day faux pas
no but seriously all in all i am
definitely filing this one under
reasonable celebrity diets and let me
tell you
it's so far a pretty empty file but on
that note that's all that i have for you
guys today
thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you
want to see me review next subscribe to
the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye